العلماء كافحوا لاثبات ان الاندماج النووي
يمكن ان يطلق طاقه اكثر من مستخدمه في
التجارب ويبدو ان الباحثين في مختبر
لورانسلا ليفربول حققوا اخيرا وبشكل مطلق
هذا الهدف وفي ملخص تقرير فينشل تايمز فان
الاندماج ادى في الاسبوعين الماضيين الى
زياده صافي الطاقه بنسبه 120 بالمئه
المختبر في عمليه يمكن اعتبارها امتلاك
طاقه الغد لانها تنتج القليل من النفايات
ولا ينتج عنها غازات دفيئه الاندماج
النووي هي تقنيه تستخدم حاليا في محطه
الطاقه النوويه
الثقيله لاستعاده الطاقه حيث تندمج
وتندريتان خفيفتان لتكوين وثقيله وهي
عمليه يتحرر معها طاقه تكفي لسد احتياجات
كبيره وبحسب تقرير فائنا شلت تايمز فانما
حققه علماء المختبر الامريكي من اختراق
ستكون له اثار كبيره في سعي العالم الى
التخلص من الوقود الاحفوري واذا تاكد هذا
الاختراق فان سنشهد لحظه تاريخيه بحيث
يمكن لفنجان صغير من وقود الهيدروجين
تزويد منزل بما يحتاجه من طاقه لمئات
السنين